SIERRA: We think we live in a world with one
set of physical rules.
If I’m holding an apple and I let it go,
it will fall to the floor.
SIERRA: But at the smallest scale - inside
of molecules and atoms - there’s another
world, where normal rules of physics cease
to exist.
A world where gravity operates differently,
where a single particle can be in more than
one place at a time.
This is the quantum world.
And it is happening all around us.
Avengers Endgame: The Quantum realm is like
its own microscopic universe.
To get in there you have to be incredibly
small.
Neil deGrasse Tyson: Particles pop in and
out of existence.
You try to measure it and it is not there
anymore, but you saw it there a moment ago.
Richard Feynman: The behavior of things on
a small scale is so fantastic, it is so wonderfully
different, so marvelously different than anything
that behaves on a large scale.
SIERRA: It’s kind of like magic, but real.
SIERRA: And right now, research teams around
the world are in the process of harnessing
this magic to build quantum computers.
And that means that you and I, dear listener,
are living during the start of a technological
revolution, just like the space age, or the
nuclear age in the past.
Some experts believe that a useful quantum
computer could be complete in just a decade.
And when they are ready, certain calculations
that would take tens of thousands of years
on a regular supercomputer could be solvable
in minutes.
SIERRA: Quantum computers will change the
world.
And we are only just starting to ask the right
questions about what that will mean.
SIERRA: I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is
Why It Matters.
Today, de-mystifying quantum computers.
GHOSE: Quantum computers are a completely
different technology, they're a whole new
type of approach to doing computing.
And for that, we need to rethink what we even
mean by computing itself.
SIERRA: This is Shohini Ghose.
She is a quantum physicist and a professor
at Wilfrid Laurier University in Waterloo,
Canada.
GIUSTINA: Imagine you live in a chess board
or a checker board and your rule set is that
you can only move on horizontal or vertical
axes.
SIERRA: And this is Marissa Guistina.
She’s a research scientist and quantum electronics
engineer at Google.
GIUSTINA: You can go forward and backwards,
left and right and that's all you know and
suppose you suddenly had access to another
rule set that allows you to move on the diagonals,
well, you're going to be able to get from
one to the opposite corner much faster if
you live in the world that allows you to use
diagonals than if you live in the world that
only allows you to move up and down, left
and right.
In our everyday lives, we are accustomed to
the rules of the way the world works.
You drop something you expect it's going to
fall.
Gravity's going to pull it down.
You don't think about that.
You take it for granted, but you could imagine
that if you had access to another universe,
if you will, with a different set of rules,
you might be able to build different tools,
and quantum computing is just that.
It's the idea that maybe if we climb into
the set of rules given to us by quantum mechanics,
we could build a tool that behaves totally
differently from the tools in our everyday
world that maybe is better at solving some
problems.
SIERRA: It's like a multiverse.
GIUSTINA: Oh, let's not get an to multiverses.
Yeah.
SIERRA: You're like, "Please don't say that."
GIUSTINA: Then we get into conflicts between
different interpretations of quantum mechanics
and it gets very philosophical.
SIERRA: Oh, my God.
Okay.
I don't want to start a rumble in the quantum
mechanics community, please.
I'll back it up.
SIERRA: Listen, if there’s one thing that
I can tell you from making this episode, is
that if it’s quantum, it’s confusing.
But one of the best ways to understand what
quantum computers are for is to compare them
to the standard computers that we’re all
used to.
GHOSE: So standard computing is actually pretty
easy because everything boils down to combining
zeros and ones.
SIERRA: Regular computers think in a binary
system using something called bits.
Bits are sort of like switches, and at any
given time, they can either be a zero or a
one.
That’s it.
Everything your computer does happens because
it is working its way through millions of
these zeros and ones.
GHOSE: All information, whether you're writing
emails, or doing some fancy calculation to
launch a rocket ship to Mars, all calculations
and information and data are just zeros and
ones.
But with quantum computing, the idea is that
we move away from restricting ourselves just
to zero and one, because if you think about
it, that's a pretty small space to start computing
in.
Instead if we can expand and think about combinations
of zeros and ones where you have some probability
of being zero and some probability of one,
then that opens up a much broader range.
And it's a little more fuzzy of course, because
we're not talking about precision zeros and
ones.
But on the other hand, you can think of it
as a much larger landscape to play in.
SIERRA: Quantum computers aren’t constrained
by the binary system of bits.
Instead, they use something called qubits.
Rather than being a zero or a one, a qubit
can be in both states simultaneously.
If you’re scratching your head right now,
you are in good company.
But one way to say it is that quantum computers
use the strange behaviors of sub-atomic particles
to solve problems.
SIERRA: So what type of sectors, or I guess
people, will be using quantum computers?
GHOSE: It's hard to predict where technology
can be applied, but we do know very specific
kinds of algorithms that a quantum computer
would provide advantages for.
So let's say if you want to simulate the behavior
of a molecule for drug development, that's
a quantum simulation, obviously you'd want
to use a quantum computer.
GIUSTINA: You could almost think of a quantum
computer and as being a little bit like a
programmable molecule.
If a chemist wants to model a molecule really
fully and they want to use a classical computer,
there's a pretty low limit as to how large
that molecule can get before we just can't
even run the simulation anymore.
The number of parameters that you have to
keep track of gets really big, but that same
kind of complexity that the molecule has that's
difficult to model with a classical computer
is actually built into the quantum computer.
It's because of the quantum mechanics that
it's difficult to model classically.
So you could almost say that the dynamics
of the molecule are the native language of
the quantum computer.
SIERRA: Right now, if you want to create a
new treatment for, say, Alzheimers, or Covid,
you have to conduct real-life experiments
in a lab for months or years.
But with quantum computers, you could potentially
simulate many of those experiments in minutes
or hours, by creating exact models of the
molecules that make up things like organs,
blood cells, or brain tissue.
Experts are very conservative about projections,
but these types of simulations could lead
to faster breakthroughs.
GHOSE: But that's only one application of
quantum simulation.
You can certainly use simulations to develop
let's say better solar cells, which are also
based on quantum properties of things like
how you can develop materials that can absorb
energy more efficiently and can store energy,
building better batteries, all of this.
And that of course relates to things like
even transportation, because then you can
talk about electric vehicles and things like
this.
WEBER: One could imagine modeling the chemical
reactions required for nuclear fusion for
fusion energy, which to Marissa's point, would
be transformational for climate change.
SIERRA: We also spoke to Kate Weber, she works
with Marissa, but on the policy end.
WEBER: Do you want to start here Marissa?
I’m sure Marissa has thoughts that she…
SIERRA: She is a Policy Lead for Quantum Computing
at Google.
WEBER: I did a PhD in molecular biology.
If I had been able to model protein interactions,
a lot of the work that I needed to do and
spent countless hours in the lab doing would
become kind of unnecessary.
I could just have predicted the results using
a quantum computer, so.
GHOSE: There's a whole general area around
optimization, finding the best solution or
the maximum or the minimum of functions.
Now, that sounds very mathematical, but in
the real world, what that means is that the
best solution could be, let's say, the best
transportation route for food supplies around
the world.
By the time they come online, they will be
able to impact so many different areas of
our society.
Whether we're talking, as I said, security
or healthcare, or even climate change questions,
anything that involves large amounts of information
processing for certain types of algorithms
would be open to the use of quantum computers,
but also perhaps in ways that are unexpected.
SIERRA: Functional quantum computers could
fundamentally alter any field or industry.
Finance, city planning, weather forecasting
- you name it!
SIERRA: Will there ever be a day, you know,
in the future when everyone is walking around
with a quantum computer in their back pocket?
GIUSTINA: You can't think about a quantum
computer as something that will ever replace
a classical computer.
It's a piece of additional hardware that helps
your computer do something that it could otherwise
never do, but that aid alone is not the whole
picture.
So quantum computers, for example, are not
very good at counting or arithmetic.
Those are tasks that are really best left
for the standard classical computer, but there
are other problems like chemical modeling,
for example, that are simply impossible for
a classical computer by itself, and when partnered
up with a capable quantum computer, then the
real magic happens.
A way to think about this could be that imagine
we're trying to develop new means of transportation
and we want to get to the moon.
Okay, we know we're going to need to develop
some pretty crazy technology to get to the
moon, time goes on, we invent the rocket,
we get to the moon, hooray, but that doesn't
mean that we now take rockets everywhere.
If you want to go to the grocery store, your
bicycle is still a better bet than the rocket.
And similar with a quantum computer, we'll
need that rocket in order to solve certain
kinds of problems, but it's not going to replace
all of the other very effective computation
tools that we rely on.
SIERRA: Can you give me a picture of what
a quantum computer looks like?
GHOSE: I can give you a picture of a type
of quantum computer.
What's interesting is that the technology
is so new that we don't even know what it
will actually be based on.
Will it be based on the solid state technologies
that we already have, for example, semiconductor
kinds of approaches and materials, or will
we be using laser beams and photonics, or
in fact, some of the earliest approaches to
quantum computers was in liquid form because
these were-
SIERRA: Whoa.
GHOSE: Yeah, these are molecules that were
in solution that were being controlled.
So that's how big the range is of what you
can visualize, maybe at which it'll be in
the form of a test tube.
SIERRA: Wow.
GHOSE: Who knows.
SIERRA: Yeah.
SIERRA: So these computers are already up
and running?
GHOSE: Well, quantum computers, they do exist
in the sense that IBM for example, has a working
quantum computer, Google has one, and there
are also new startups that are building their
own hardware.
But this is sort of like saying we have computers
back in the days in the '60s, if you look
up history books or Google the earliest computers,
you'll get these photos of rooms full of these
dials and switches and-
SIERRA: Totally like a whole room, very loud.
Yeah.
Remington Rand Univac: In the heart of the
Univac, the electronic central computer, capable
of making over 2000 mathematical calculations
per second.
GHOSE: You know, when we see those photos,
we think of that as kind of primitive computers.
And now we have super high tech, cool gadgets.
So I'd say that quantum computers that do
exist today are kind of like those old '60s-style,
regular computers.
GIUSTINA: Some of the initial interesting
quantum computing started in the 80s and '90s
and really just kind of daydreaming about
what would it look like, but we also found
that actually implementing that hardware is
extremely difficult, because of course we're
trying to build something that doesn't behave
according to our everyday rules.
So actually very early on, it was found that
quantum information is fundamentally error
prone, you've got your quantum computer in
some state and then it just goes poof and
isn't there anymore, and in order to get around
that we need a technology known as quantum
error correction.
Any useful quantum computer is going to be
robust against these kinds of errors.
So now we're talking about needing millions
of physical qubits, and right now we've demonstrated
something on the order of tens to a hundred
of physical qubits.
So we’re not only a ways away in terms of
the number of physical qubits that we need
to make, but also the performance that we
need to see.
So that's a ways out, but I will say that
not too long ago, we were saying, "Oh, it
was 20-year out technology."
It was perpetually 20-year out technology.
Now it's around a decade, so we're definitely
making progress, but there's also a lot of
progress still to come.
SIERRA: With any new technology, of course,
there is the potential for misuse and risk.
2001: A Space Odyssey: I know that you and
frank were planning to disconnect me and I
am afraid that is something I cannot allow
to happen.
SIERRA: Yeah no not that kind of risk.
More like this:
TED, Vikram Sharma: And when quantum computers
arrive, in the next 10 - 15 years they will
even more rapidly crack the complex mathematics
that underlies many of our encryption systems
today.
Indeed the quantum computer is likely to turn
our present security castle into a mere house
of cards.
WEBER: The one very concrete risk that there's
been a lot of focus on is the predicted ability
of quantum computers to break RSA encryption
and there's a lot of work happening now to
get ahead of that.
The U.S. National Institute of Standards in
Technology is running a standards process
to develop standards for post quantum cryptography.
Now these are cryptographic algorithms that
use classical computing, but are expected
to be resistant to quantum computers.
That is one specific risk that important to
think about and address now, because there
is a possibility that adversaries could download
large amounts of encrypted information, store
it for 15 years and then when we have a fault
tolerant quantum computer that can break Shor's
algorithm, which is what would break RSA encryption,
they could then decrypt that information.
And if it's still important that it be kept
secret in a couple decades, it's sort of important
to think about protecting it now.
GHOSE: So a decade or two sounds like a long
time, but if you think about one thing, for
example, that we are all learning, especially
now during the pandemic, to be very careful
about is healthcare, as well as healthcare
records and our information.
And if you think about the average person's
healthcare records, they don't expire in a
month or two months.
We're talking about a lifetime.
So 10 or 20 years may seem like it’s a long
time, but imagine if let's say 10 or 20 years
from now somebody turns on a quantum computer
and can hack every single one of your passwords
and take a look at all of your private data,
for everybody around the world, that would
be kind of bad.
And so if that is even a possibility now,
we should be thinking about it now and caring
about it now, meaning how do we protect against
that kind of situation, who gets to control
that kind of technology, what else can you
use these kinds of quantum computers for?
SIERRA: So I'd love to pivot back a bit to
policy.
So what are the biggest ethical or policy
concerns when it comes to quantum computing?
WEBER: So without knowing exactly what the
really powerful applications for quantum computing
are going to be, it's really difficult to
identify what the biggest ethical concerns
will be.
But we can say that they'll come in a couple
of buckets.
And, I think when people think about this
now and say ethics, they actually are talking
about two things.
One is, what are the applications for quantum
computing that raise concerns?
And, then the other is related to this access
question, who has access to this technology
and will it further existing inequalities
in access to this to technology?
So on the first, the lack of knowledge about
what the applications will be, means that
it's challenging to address now.
One of the reasons that I think we see so
much policymaker focus is there is a belief
that there will be some defense-related applications
for the technology and, of course, that's
where our view is that these frameworks for
thinking about emerging technology deployment
will become important as these applications
begin to be discovered.
SIERRA: We spoke to some experts about this
and there are national security concerns.
Again, the biggest issue is the predicted
ability of quantum computers to break existing
encryption.
SIERRA: It’s not just our personal data
at stake, quantum computers could also be
powerful tools for cyberwarfare.
And there are other concerns too - they could
be used to develop counter-stealth technology,
anti-submarine technology, military AI, and
could even be used to model more advanced
nuclear weapons.
SIERRA: But, just like in the civilian world,
the exact military and security implications
are not yet understood.
SIERRA: At the other end of the spectrum,
there are different policy concerns.
For example, who might get left out of the
quantum moment?
WEBER: On the access piece, it's also important
that we think about reaching communities that
are less likely to have the resources to access
quantum computers or even through education
outreach efforts.
Government funding is super important here,
both at the undergraduate, graduate education
level, but also the government has something
called the "Q12 Partnership," which is focused
on exposing even kids, school-age kids to
at least quantum computing and quantum technologies
as a concept, the thinking being that the
earlier you broaden the pipeline, the more
likely you are to get people from underrepresented
groups interested.
GIUSTINA: Yeah, I was waiting from when I
was three.
SIERRA: So that's right.
Yeah.
That's funny.
WEBER: I don't think we've discussed the preschool
audience yet, Marissa, but I could try it
out on my two-and-a-half and five-year-old.
SIERRA: There you go.
WEBER: We have this Quantum Computing for
Babies book, actually, so..
GIUSTINA: I had seen that.
SIERRA: So obviously, you both work at Google,
but are there other companies that are working
on this?
I mean is this also something that the U.S.
Government is working on as well, whether
in partnership with private companies or within
the government?
WEBER: There are several other large tech
companies that are developing quantum computers
too.
There are Amazon, Microsoft, IBM.
Also, a lot of U.S. startups, several of whom
have recently gone public or will go public
soon.
So in terms of US government investment, they
are not, as far as we know, directly funding
large-scale quantum computing hardware development
in the way that these other companies are.
But the government does provide a lot of R&D
support from quantum computing and other quantum
technologies, mostly through the National
Quantum Initiative, which was signed into
law in 2018.
SIERRA: The National Quantum Initiative is
an Act of Congress.
It gives the United States a plan for advancing
quantum computing in the name of safeguarding
national and economic security.
SIERRA: So what other countries are working
on this?
GHOSE: I think by now almost every major government
or conglomerate is looking into quantum kinds
of applications and technologies.
So the U.S. has certainly announced a couple
of rounds of multi-billion dollar funding
for this on the research sector side.
India has announced funding.
The European Union has its own funding.
China has huge amounts of funding that they're
pouring into it, which dwarfs everybody else.
SIERRA: Many see the US’s biggest quantum
competitor as China.
And right now, China is building a $10 billion
quantum supercenter.
DW News: China has announced their development
of the power quantum computer in the world,
President Xi Jingping has said that research
and development in quantum science is an urgent
matter of national concern and the country
has invested heavily in this technology.
It has become a world leader in the field.
WEBER: There is definitely a competition.
A lot of the policy conversations these days
certainly have a geopolitical competition
lens behind them.
In the U.S., of course, there is a big focus
on the competition with China and we've seen
impressive results coming out of China in
the past couple of years.
You know, it's clear that they're putting
huge investments into the technology, they're
making a lot of progress.
It is something that I think we need to be
really careful that these geopolitical concerns
don't stifle scientific collaboration.
As we've been emphasizing throughout this
conversation, we are at a very early stage
in this technology.
It's really still at the fundamental research
stage, and one thing that we know is that
collaboration is super important for advancing
fundamental research.
So, you know, policies that can foster collaboration
amongst like-minded countries to more quickly
realize the impacts of quantum computing,
I think, are super important.
As somebody who has worked in science policy,
I mean it's at the heart of the broader U.S.
approach to research and innovation, and it's
what has established us as a leader.
I think we don't want to lose that.
SIERRA: Every country wants to get ahead in
the quantum game, but too much emphasis on
competition and secrecy could stifle progress.
Part of the balancing act is prioritizing
security while also working with the brightest
minds abroad, and when possible, bringing
those minds to the U.S. through smart immigration
policy.
GIUSTINA: It's already hard to recruit.
We already are kind of low on experts, and
that is a big critical piece of being able
to develop the technology, so any way in which
we restrict ourselves is a hindrance.
We really need to be able to access as many
brains as possible and nurture and nourish
as many brains as possible to make them available
for this kind of technology development.
SIERRA: As we think about who is at the table,
as this gets built, I sort of want to pivot
to something else and ask you about it.
Much of the STEM world is still dominated
by men, AI, blockchain, you know everything.
So we even did a whole episode about STEM
and I, myself, spent a few years in tech.
We've seen in the past what happens when technology
is built by one relatively homogeneous group.
So my question is do you think, or do you
have concerns about that, that could be applied
to the quantum computing space?
GHOSE: Yes, it's already happening that the
same homogenous group is developing the technology
and yes, of course it's an issue.
So I was looking at some of the sort of founding
boards and so on, the executive level membership
and leadership of these companies.
And it is shockingly homogenous, in the sense
that almost every board I looked at was all
white men.
And that, on one hand, that's not surprising,
but on the other hand, it's also depressing
that it's continuing the culture of what we
already see in Silicon Valley, for example.
There is more conversation, I will say, around
these issues.
People are trying to find ways to open up
the field more and bring in a more diverse
group for the workforce, but it's slow.
And until we have change at the leadership
level, I don't think these approaches will
be anything more than token.
And I see a lot of that happen.
SIERRA: There’s still time to shape quantum
computing - who builds it, who has access
to it, and how we protect ourselves and our
privacy.
Time to ensure that their enormous power is
directed at the right problems, and includes
everyone.
SIERRA: It’s all pretty exciting, also confusing,
and a little scary, but exciting.
GHOSE: If we do build better technologies
and we are at some point able to build structures
and processes to be using and making these
kinds of technologies accessible to everybody
then I feel, of course, that could unlock
a future that would be amazing.
And I'd love to be able to be part of that.
SIERRA: You just make me excited about this.
I really, you know, if podcasting doesn't
work out, I'll start my new life as a quantum
physicist.
GHOSE: Come on over anytime.
Or maybe I'll become a podcaster.
SIERRA: Exactly.
GHOSE: And where we go, we just do it together.
SIERRA: Yeah!
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we’d love it if you
could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better.
It really does help us get noticed and we
appreciate it.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Rafaela Siewert is our associate podcast producer.
Our intern this semester is Roshni Rangwani.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire Felter.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass, Jeff Reinke
and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!